hey Conan O'Brien here with another
clueless gamer today I'm playing the new
god of war game for the PlayStation 4
this is a testosterone-fueled fantasy so
who better to join me than the ultimate
he-man mr. Bill Hader bill what's the
new show Barry congratulations thank you
people love the show thank you it's a
new thing for you you're you're a man
who murders you still get to be funny
it's everything yes yeah it's not my
life but you know what's based on your
life a little bit you murdered some you
tell someone something and confidence
and they just don't you should get out
my friend in here who always tells me
what to do in here Erin Blair Erin come
on in here yeah relax yeah you know I'm
behind this is a fun game I'm really
excited
you play Kratos The Ghost of Sparta you
basically are you're a servant of Ares
who's the god of war the previous God of
War and you're tricked by areas into
killing your wife and your daughter why
don't we just start smashing something
can I just say what happens when this
game starts
when this game starts is the only single
insufficient please tell us about this
games so number eight in the seven
batters elaborate early installment of
the where's your juice box where's your
Trapper Keeper what am I am in seventh
grade I love that you and I finally get
some bullies we married at this point oh
good have a son named it Reyes okay and
when he brought me a big story yes but
your wife has died Oh hilarious it's so
then this game starts right before we're
gonna start you've lit your wife's
funeral pyre and you're gonna take her
ashes to the highest peak so we're gonna
hide with with our son we're gonna teach
him how to hunt you know if you just
walked in you'd think this man was
chasing okay you know with an axe yeah
that's the kid's leg now that's my
solder sir sir leave the boy alone
you're not
this is that your mother oh that's not
your mother your mother's dead remember
when your mother died and we burn her
the therapist said I probably shouldn't
have let you watch that but I think kids
need to grow up fast son why don't you
try jumping first this is recreating the
awkward silences I've had with my father
so how about the red sock yes kill it
son
this is like Donald Trump jr. it's
precious and rare and it's caused us no
harm I want to wear it so press right on
the d-pad so you just you're in this
deep like a real bed right there's the
Tron help bad Conan okay sir
sir we're looking for the elk
[Applause]
oh he was fortunately he was made of
pumpkin so easy to kill son you didn't
see that if you missed this I'm going to
be furious just use its antlers to open
a nightclub there you go dummy
I told you not to kill that dear son the
end you're embarrassing me I stab your
teeth
I just wanted direction
all right well
yeah yeah you're properly so now let's
have a light lunch what do you guys
think of the games there's more talking
than I thought there was yeah I don't
really care about the relationship
between the dad and son I've got a son
in real life and I'm I'm checking out of
that I don't think anybody's gonna play
a video game and going you know what
this video game has really taught me
that I need to have a better
relationship with my son yeah all right
what's next there this is your house
this is your home but I'll not give you
decent they'll come a time when you
masturbate just walk into the cabinet
already noises first look again let's do
some war
amber when we were in that band together
[Laughter]
from amoeba right my [ __ ] to work look I
did your tattoos for you for free I
[Applause]
haven't done any of this by now this is
you know we haven't touched the
controller for 45 no no no dude
okay so now we're gonna skip ahead so
basically there's this woman The Witch
of the woods Oh a woman now be
refreshing yeah
we go to the smartest man in all the
realms Mamere and we cut his head off
because he's in prison of the trade and
now we need to revive lemierre's head so
going back to the widow's alright I
guess let's go into the turtle now yeah
like a couple of nerds in a nerd story
oh they're showing the turtle house this
is awkward there's a real estate person
mijo this is the living room and it's
the sunken level Oh like this
we can go on date you gotta kill this
guy those are all just souls I'm just
like the guy in the woods what's going
on over there
[Laughter]
got him or what do you guys think the
killing is very cathartic I thought you
broke through a lot of levels of anger
yeah I did I worked out some stuff but
God of War and I think I can now use it
in my life there are nine unsolved
murder I think the kid is you know
doesn't do much Yeah right
all you should be able to kill the kid
man he gets it on with the girl in the
term that turtle girl yes by the real
estate lady yeah when the guy who's just
ahead yeah he he's like the sidekick
they gotta use him as like an electic
yes my flight my Delta it's delayed
you can see the other video games every
Judith team cover calm
slash clueless gamer a huge thanks to
one of the funniest people alive Bill
Hader put
you